why is equal to that express it in the
form well any who's the only angle
formed that you like okay how am I going
to do this you can see the causes first
right
so automatically it's going to be one of
these cause expansions that I'm gonna
use makes it illegal okay
secondly you see there's a plus here and
causes the one that turns it around so
therefore I'm going to go for this last
one here okay so the natural form for
this will be r cos x minus alpha okay
so the way you're going to go about it
is expand out this dip on both the
right-hand side okay so I'm gonna get
rid of three I'm gonna skip a lion and
I'm gonna go straight to the pot where
it's factorize and I can see the
coefficients nicely okay so I'm gonna
get okay see this is just my expansion
and now I compare coefficients
so here are my two equations okay
three three that's aa cos alpha right
and one is sine alpha because I picked
the right fall I don't have any
negatives flopping around in here okay
so you can see how because both of these
are positive right think about it
because both both are positive
that's what lands you in the first
quadrant that's why the angle I'm going
to get is acute to smallest possible
angle okay all right what's my next step
I can't wait I'm going to use these two
together to work out the ANFO to you
okay so I can combine them and you can
actually go straight to this step that R
is equal to and it's like Pythagoras
right so it's going to be this square
plus this square this question now
yesterday did that
did anyone I diverted to your own
balance abilities good yeah okay so
there's the first reason number one ah
the reason why we said why do I have to
introduce this number at the front it's
because we know the amplitude has change
so it goes higher than the previous one
an amplitude is just a oh it's like
we're how fast are you going it's a it's
a positive value right how much do you
weigh no one who weighs four - you know
right they don't so there's the first
thing okay because R represents a
quantity amplitude that's why it's got
to be positive is a sec away think
Amanda mode remember you know over here
we said that really all of these are
sort of equivalent to each other right
like you can turn this sign into that
side you just add or subtract 2pi you
can do the same thing with cosine you
can even turn a sign into a cosine by
doing what what's the relationship yeah
because the car in cosine just means
complement okay so for instance
next is cause of final two - so you can
convert between them willy-nilly
okay now snapping a minus sign out the
front for instance right so suppose my R
was minus 1 okay what difference would
that make
well this is what Silex like normally
right and this is what minus sign looks
like but they're really just the same
with a shift okay it's just the phase is
different in fact it should be half the
way that's sine X possible - pipe it
doesn't matter which way you go cuz
you'll end up with the same okay so
being that you could actually choose R
equals some negative value but the
question is why would you it just kind
of makes it more complicated for you so
number one because that amplitude it
makes sense to pick the positive number
to picking the negative just makes it
more awkward to get a different angle
different you'll have a different shift
in order to account for the minus sign
at the front
okay but don't do it just take the
positive oh okay just don't do it is
equal to two okay
man I've got that I'm going to bring
that back to these equations here so for
instance I can say sine alpha should be
one yeah now I can also notice that
since both sine alpha and cos alpha are
positive right therefore I'm gonna have
an acute value sorry so therefore what
answer I'm looking for
okay so now I've got my heart got my
alpha come back here and I can say Y is
equivalent to 2 cos x minus just be
careful and remember the form the e
chose at the beginning X minus pi at
6:00 okay right now one more example
before you sit before I sit you at once
to the the questions here right I said
look you go back to your natural forms
the four of them and you pick the best
one the one that will give you you know
an acute angle okay a nice sort of
figures here James ruse exam setters a
real jerks and I'm whatever right so
very often what they'll say is look
here's a here's a son of two wave
functions okay but we want you to put it
into the wrong one okay now here's the
thing remember all of these are wave
functions they're all equivalent in
different ways right you just have to
pick different values for alpha
essentially okay so how do you do it
when it's not the right form
okay the first thing you could do is do
it with the right form and then do what
we've been doing you know add 2 pi or
use use this to turn a sign into a purse
on a song like that okay you could do
that however what ends up happening is
you have to go through all of this work
anyway and then to get from your result
to the result that they very selfishly
expected you to get you've got to do
maybe three or four lines of working
just to make sure you get the right
result
okay so you have this plus extra work
okay a better way to do it is just to
look at this awkward form and then do it
the way that you normally would have
okay but you're gonna have some
negatives in here okay so let's go
through quickly and squeeze it in over
here let's do it with the wrong form
okay cuz I can basically guarantee the
next exam will have one question where
it's the right form and another question
where's the wrong one okay
what specifically there's one question
where they just let you choose so you've
picked the best one and then there's
another one where they jerks they do
this too okay so like I said you do it
just the same way so let's expand out on
the right hand side okay so the first
thing to notice this is actually not as
bad as it could be but I've got cosine
here
and here I've got sine pause so let's
put it in the right order okay this is
going to be sine X there's a 1 out of
front okay this is going to be root 3
and okay if there was a negative on one
of these for example if it was root 3
cos x minus sine X then you'd want to
have the minus inside that number
because you're gonna need that for
yourself taste equations in a minute
okay all right now what's on the
right-hand side X and you compare
coefficients just like you did before
okay but watch out for what matches up
to watch
okay now let's see I've got now because
we actually have the advantage of having
worked out are already are still going
to be the same okay so now we're not
gonna work out these anglers you're
gonna get for instance let's do cos
alpha cos alpha is for one on ok now
pause for a minute before we had sine
alpha equals one untruth right but now
I've got close the reason it's different
is because it's a different form that
were using okay so you ought to expect a
different phase shift both of these are
still positive so I actually am still a
cute but it's going to be a different
acute angle namely what's the exact
value for this one in degrees at 67 pi/3
radians so you see how choosing this
different function up here gave you
different shifts at the end
so therefore root 3 cos X is equivalent
to two okay so can you see can you see
how they're the same right can you see
how there's the pile to shift in the
other way around yeah yeah the same way
I got it yup right so I'm gonna take the
square root of a squared plus B squared
which is the square root of one plus
three you can go straight to this line